[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
j't'emmène au vent
je tends mélange t'emmène au vent je
vous emmène au vent vous propose de
faire un petit voyage pour ça le reste
d'entre elles elles vous sentir de plus
en plus et j'ai tout simplement laisser
flotter vous laisser emmener plus en
plus au sud à la loupe sur l'asie et
vous laisser emporter
or le manque d'études
on traverse le ciel en avion voilà d'un
point a à un point b de manière efficace
et bien là je propose de voyager dans le
ciel de visiter le ciel alors on se
laissera emporter
on va au moins tout doucement on va de
plus en plus haut on est porté aux
caresses l'on effleure le mont blanc la
visite en fait on visite le ciel alors
sur votre droite vous avez un vol d'oies
sauvages qui s'envole à tire d'aile une
destination intel en dessous vous avez
un nuage se moquer éclatant qui nous
donne plus en plus fait le caresser
plonger dedans ressortir pouvez vous
laisser entouré par des onglets vous les
voyez qui vous tourner tour s'enivrer
d'azur de soleil d'air pur
cet esprit car une partie reportés par
les ifi
si j'en suis là reader ça n'a rien avoir
avec la drogue
tout a commencé il ya quelques années
j'étais contrôleur aérien et j'ai encore
une situation que vous avez vous connu
je contemplais un soleil et j'étais
mariée je regardais la lumière dorée sur
les nuages
j'avais justement absorbé par cette
beauté que j'avais envie de plonger dans
table liste de l'énergie et de me
laisser aller de voler entre le ciel et
les nuages tranquillement laisser porter
et de naviguer dans le ciel
le levier aussi longtemps que sans
limite de temps naviguez naviguer des
heures d'avis qu'il est jour verdict et
des semaines même partir en l'air comme
par lambert larguesa de lionel du rêve
croire mais elle
assez rapidement j'ai essayé je me suis
dit je sais qu'on peut le faire qu'à
trouver les moyens et je savais le rôle
technique dans l'aéronautique
je suis à clichy calculer pendant des
semaines pendant des mois
calcul j'ai fait théories et des
expériences cherchait une idée à
plusieurs et ndé dit pas c'est pas mal
là j'en ai parlé à un muscle est elle
d'accord mais dix ans pour développer la
première partie de notre prototype il
nous faudra au minimum un lion
personnellement je vous déconseille et
je m'en vais de ce pas dire que vous en
a parlé avec mon associé
ultra positif chaîné quelques heures en
remettre et je me suis attelé à la tâche
pour ces ag atg café offert en dur en
fait j'ai parlé serait cette réalisation
à mon tour est fini et l'infini des
associations sont venues bab jdid sein
des chercheurs que s'intéresser et tous
ensemble on est arrivé quand même à
quelque chose toutes sortes plus
intelligible même d'en faire industriel
du moins fabrication et on est arrivé à
un ballon parce que c'est comme ça on
peut voler le clan toxiques et emballe
qui fait fait 65 m2 au total qui pèse
une tonne
pauvre m 65 même celles épluchées coeur
fragile est anormal au dessus petit
facial en dessous et entre les deux un
régulateur a réglé la thématique quelque
chose qui nous permet de monter et
descendre autant on veut juste avec de
l'énergie sur ce que sont ces ballons
traditionnel c'est peu la abords du
sable 2 reçoivent et pour monter une
petite pelle on l'a dans le sable pour
descendre on est dehors on tire et un
clavier soudre dont il vient de gaz donc
on en croit me sens assez longtemps mais
des affrontements depuis d'être gazés
faut se poser nous nous et il tient
essayé de remplacer ça et ça a marché
montre
62 oh tout léger c'est parti mon volume
tant qu'on veut temps quelle énergie
solaire on peut monter descendre il ya
des batteries pour tenir la nuit on les
calcule à ce qu'on ait une ancienne
correctement et cela peut voler un mois
lancée actuellement le plan qui a été
fait sans escale chez vers ses dix neuf
jours et les vendeurs voici un mois
c'est un peu une dimension olympique le
ciel alors dans un mois on va se laisser
porter par les dents un ulcère
seigneurie des fausses diriger un jeu où
on va pas n'importe où même en ballon
peut se diriger
parce qu'en fait c'est une vraie à tous
les religions un concept à 200 mètres du
sol vous pouvez très bien
elle sera portée par un vent qui va par
exemple vers le haut
et puis ali m d'altitude c'était avant
qu'il a portés vers l'est sur est à 6000
mètres d'altitude et un autre qui
l'amène à l'eau et à partir de ça
attention des lol là maintenant d'asie
on va se retrouver dans trois jours en
grèce où ai-je donc ouverts à toutes les
possibilités en à bras chritian juan
gris noir la pologne peut tout faire
simplement ce qu'il faut c'est connaître
la manière dont fonctionnent les vents
et ça ça a beaucoup évolué sur les
dernières examine ce qui arrivait à
mobiliser l'atmosphère entre avis c'est
pas simple c'est du gros calculateurs
certes les choses de leur ferme dis
c'est que oui en techno qui est nouvelle
mais ce qui nous permet vraiment rester
plus longtemps et d'aller plus longtemps
en l'air c'est de connaître le milieu
dans lequel on évolue
c'est l'accès à la connaissance de
l'environnement qui va nous permettre de
dieu ça c'est quelque chose ce sont un
concept et la main personnellement c'est
comme
grande satisfaction en découle est alors
sur ce vol d'un mois pour prévoir si on
se projette
c'est difficile dans les études derrière
moins de 50 est là parce que le vent
l'afrique
même si on est immobile nous par rapport
à la normale on est comme un bouchon sur
la solution qu'on sent pas du tout
landreau on était à 6000 mètres
d'altitude - 35 grand soleil pour les
hauts revenus
ce n'est pas devant l'ag pas dedans même
si on a fait rentrer benêt jusqu'à 320
indiqué mme dati si vous avez des jets
j'estime qu'ils vont pas battery mode
jet qui vont à 300 à l'heure de
retrouver sensiblement vers ath au
quotidien c'est difficile de faire moins
de 1000 km par jour s'il veut dire que
sur un vol d'un oiseau jour même trente
mille kilomètres alors la manière simple
demande ce serait de partir et puis se
laisser porter tranquillement les restes
ya beaucoup de peur d'une information
avec de l'ouest bon et il doit se porter
de la grèce mais en ce moment
diplomatiquement n'a pas encore ses
portes au top parce qu'il ya la russie
très grand un grand terrain de grenoble
mais surtout si on emmène des capteurs
qui portent pas très content donc autant
de montréal là on va suivre l'avis de
michel strogoff on va survoler le
francilien vous plonger le revers dans
les bacs est parfait
la moins tant ses comptes bonne forme
c'est la ville si vous avez un ami qui
ambassadeur de russie
on comprend pour l'instant ce qu'on fait
c'est que l'on va vers le noble dans la
vallée des moulins de l'ordre doit au
nord vers l'article naturellement nord
du canada nord enfin les états unis fils
et entoure aussi averti changer petit
gars sympa on évolue donc entre 0 et 8
mm et un gamme des petites choses à
vendre c'est que
e à lille i m yours une petite laine
tout du moins 50
et cette faute d'avoir tout un tas de
choses comme ça qu'il faut prévoir donc
on a construit une nacelle un peu plus
affectée que justin d'allier dossier
c'est un beau morceau de tout en carbone
très dur et c'est en plus un mois c'est
vraiment habiter le ciel quand on a fait
un charmant petit 2,8 mètres carrés 4
mai carioca l'asthme alors très sympa
vis-à-vis traversant nord sud est ouest
vue imprenable top trop fort d'une herbe
seule chambre dite chanel dior salle à
manger possède pilotage en croquant m
s'est dit en public et la forme pour
l'enfer en voyant drones aux orages des
photos du ballon et puis il faut prévoir
ça le nom ça demain salle de sport m
un jeu le pays sur lequel non seulement
on peut produire de l'électricité et à
ce père et ensuite cela 30 jours ea
mobile dont lui même car et c'est pas
forcément père fera donc il faut
centaines il faut garder beaucoup de
spécialistes se penchent du médecin qui
se penche sur votre expédition parce que
c'est intéressant d'un point de vue
physiologique pour ces questions
finement pour ces questions aussi de
réalisme attitude on est entre 0 et 8 mm
en cent jours je 80 ils peuvent
comparables donc ça les intéresse nous
devons par des capteurs mais super jd
qui font qu'on est au coeur du drame
directement lui par l'université à paris
toujours avec le sol surtout dans les
montées ou non de surveiller un très bon
on l'a on a aussi plus que les sites ou
les sciences spécialistes l'atmosphère
de synthèse votre fils de vol il est
libre on travaille des catcheurs
bordelais pas valdes de science nous
l'avait fait citer à bord et pourquoi on
va créer des données inédites
il ya aussi les détergents qui modélise
trajectoire que ça intéresse parce que
on est arrivé à plusieurs modèles
mathématiques entre 0 et 1 8 m non je
vais bien voir comment son bord d'autres
veulent et sont un classique au bon
escient la transposer ses modèles à 25
mètres a indiqué mme dauba saint jean et
la soul rock quelque chose de nouveau
c'est que par rapport à l'avenir actuel
de voler vers la sphère alors ça c'est
cette partie qui est au dessus des
avions après 28 km d'altitude jusqu'à 60
kg
c'est parti on va vers 1,5 km de haut
actuellement donc part seul en scène est
atteint nous sommes une heure et demie
c'est le timbre ou en ballon et frappe
mais là où actuellement son fessier au
lard bleu et or de sources proches nous
annonce aussi que ç'a permis de
l'invention de défi qu'on savait rien de
monter descendre dans vos domaines
on commence à monter on sera dans
travail et ont envie n'est déjà pas
pareil pour les cendres s'est doucement
on entend des possibles du bas et a le
côté qui est sympa c'est que ça fait un
vol d'où aussi à chaque fois important
et enroulé pour l'arc sûrement son bal
bacon à perdre donc à mon père un ballon
lagarde
plutôt sympa ça fait des pigments et
surtout ce qui ce qui change beaucoup la
donne c'est que quand on se marre pas
liés on peut s'intégrer à une
circulation r&d avait bien que
actuellement
si vous montrent également l'objet de
monter au dessus des déserts donc il
faut qu'il parle l'avion qui parce qu'il
contrôle aérien bonjour je vais de 0 à
25 km pendant une heure et demi
abandonné devant l'appartement de faire
passer les airs entre 14 alors que là si
vous pouvez faire des pauses m'en voulez
vous intégrer
on a droit de voyager un peu mon voeu
est l'avantagé c'est qu'on n'est plus
confiné au désert ou branleur canadien
ou haqqani comme c'est le cas
actuellement
pourquoi voler au-dessus d'un site
direct alors tout ça ça a été j'ai
quelque chose qu'on a de bien plus d'un
an fil en aiguille et spécialistes qui
sont penchés dessus on travaille et de
jean spatiale européenne les pièces
national des études spatiales il vola il
vous êtes beaucoup c'est une innovation
et il a fallu monter une entreprise
autour aussi structure on a bien ça une
autre aventure
et de fil en aiguille le lutteur est 7e
dans l'ue et de vous emmener à 25 le
médiatique parce que c'est bien beau
d'emmener des peuls dans par morné les
jedis scientifique si je serais allé
visiter
vous imaginez porter sont toujours
comportement mince et les 10 années à 9
kilomètres de là vous arrêter pour père
dépassé les éléments du jeu vous
reprenez vous regardez d'autres talion
du frontier à 20 km commence à observer
la courbure de la terre 25 km vous êtes
de renoir de l'espace et part fait
observer les doivent pour emmener n'y
paraît et quand vous pencher le regard
vous avez plus de 1000 km de queue de
pie voyage près toute la france et une
partie d'italie et la subissent oui et
puis descente
alors comment on fait pour en arriver à
ce sont 138 l'on se retrouve père cheikh
en 5e m vient surprendre depuis le début
janvier voir comment on la fait décoller
sa - est arrivé comme on a appris hier
on est parti tout simplement duré ce
qu'on a fait c'est qu on s'émerveillait
yves hocher on s'aimait arriver ça nous
a permis de rêver qui a comme des
enfants c'est merdique
nous devrons à vivre à jamais comme des
enfants fait on n'a pas peur on veut se
dépasser on essaye et là il ya le real
qui rattrape
c'est reparti là il faut passer
l'association car il sait que toutes les
autres viennent nous aider on se relève
et on recommence
et ça on va voir comment ces détails les
dames
donc c'est une méthode de travail que
vous maîtrisez tous à fond puisque c'est
à peu près comme ça que vous avez appris
à marcher
du coup ma faim le bilan c'est que après
on va voler et faire décoller ce bref
c'est peu c'est comme apprendre à
marcher c'est un jeu d'enfant
du coup je m'embêtais une seule chose ce
soir j'ai une navigation à faire c'est
revenez comme des enfants et je vole
merci beaucoup